I tell any actor any I told my own kids
this if you're reading for something
just assume you're not going to get the
part and that'll free you if anything
it'll free you to make a bolder Choice
maybe and what will happen it's more
important than even the director
watching you do the reading it's the
casting director because they they work
with directors all the time so they see
you do something that's kind of
interesting and bold they'll tell the
director of another project they're
working on well maybe you know this act
is not quite what you're looking for but
they're interesting you should meet them
and you never know what happens did you
really do that when you were a young
actor go in and say I'm not going to get
this no it's not so easy but you you do
assume that you're not going to get it
I've gone for I've read for things over
and over and over again and I've done it
every which way to a point of absurdity
and at the end of the day they just
wanted somebody I wasn't quite right no
matter how you sliced it so they got
somebody with some a name back